Let's start with an example. Let's say your in the shower and as your turning
the shower handle off and the water stops, the shower handle breaks off. Now
you immediately assess what this event means to you. You might become very
stressed out when you realize that your going to have to call a plumber, that's
going to be expensive, your going to have to make time to meet the plumber,
your going to have to clean your apartment to make it presentable, you had to
find a place to put your cat, so the cat doesn't attack the plumber, when the
plumber comes in. And the list goes on, and on, and on, about what stress
results just from breaking off your shower handle. This was the primary
appraisal, you quickly assessed what happened and your emotional response to
it, which most certainly would have been a negative emotional response, because
you're stressed about everything you have to do, just to fix the shower handle.
However, when this actually did happen to me, I stopped, took a second to think
about it, and my stress level actually decreased. First, I thought, this is a
great opportunity to get a new shower handle and new shower head. Second, I
thought, how lucky I was the shower handle didn't break off when the water was
still running, because I don't know how to turn the water off in my apartment.
So, I would've just been standing there with a broken shower handle in my hand,
and the water just running, I wouldn't have known what to do. Third, I thought
that I needed to clean my apartment anyway, so this is a great opportunity to
make it nice and presentable.